solve using the elimination method and
they tell us the sum of two numbers is
70. their difference is 24. what are the
two numbers so let's use this first
sentence let's construct an equation
from this first sentence let's construct
a constraint the sum of two numbers
let's call those numbers x and y so
their sum x plus y
is equal to 70. that's what this first
sentence tells us the second sentence
says their difference is 24. so that
means that x minus y is equal to 24.
we're just going to assume that x is the
larger of the two numbers and y is a
smaller one so when you take the
difference like this you get positive
24. so we have a system of two equations
with two unknowns and they want us to
solve it using the elimination method so
let's do that
so we can literally just if we were to
just add these two equations we would on
the left hand side we would have a
positive y and we would have a negative
y over here and they would cancel out so
if we were to just add these two
equations we would be able to eliminate
the y's so let's do that so x plus y
plus x minus y well the plus y and the
minus y cancel out and you're just left
with an x plus an x which is 2x and then
that is going to be equal to 70 plus 24.
70 plus 24 is 94. and i want to make it
very clear and i mentioned it in
previous videos that this process of
adding the equations to each other this
is nothing new we're really just adding
the same thing to both sides we could do
it as to both sides of this equation you
could say we're adding 24 to both sides
of this equation over here we're
explicitly adding 24 to the 70 and over
here you could say we could add 24 to x
plus y but the second constraint tells
us that x minus y is the same thing as
24. so we're adding the same thing to
both sides here we're calling it 24 here
we're calling it x minus y and we were
able to eliminate the y so we get 2x is
equal to 94. now we can divide both
sides of this equation by 2
and we are left with x is equal to
what is that 40
47 and now we can substitute back into
either one of these equations to solve
for y so let's try this first one over
here so we have 47
plus y is equal to 70. can subtract 47
from both sides of this equation
so we subtract 47 and we are left with y
is equal to
what is this 23 y is equal to
23. and you can verify that it works if
you add the two numbers 47 plus 23 you
definitely get 70. and then if you take
47 minus 23 you definitely get 24. so it
definitely meets both constraints